I'm most concerned about creating
employment as far as the global context
because Europe still not drawing
china growth is slowing down and what
Wilbur Ross said us
on television couple of days ago but
fact the China is not growing its own
person anymore but actually it's growing
at four to five percent these would be
this is the most important issue right
now turbulence is that we've seen on the
financial markets have to be watched
very carefully we've seen that Chinese
authorities have tried to stabilize the
situation but it is very difficult to go
against the market so this is need to be
monitored on one hand it's certainly
reason for concern for all the other
economies that the Chinese giant is a
bit less furious in its growth on the
other hand this also shows how erroneous
some extrapolations into the long-term
of current trends can be and all those
who were preaching that in a few years
China would overtake all the rest of the
world in terms of economic might will
have to reflect
there's many factors of flow china is
our biggest trading partner but the
united states is our third biggest
trading partner and we're seeing strong
growth in the United States low energy
prices help us on the one hand because
we import a lot of oil on the other hand
we export a lot of gas so that's not
necessarily helpful to our domestic gas
prices Australia has a diversified
economy much more diversified than
people appreciate and therefore we will
be able to cope with whatever happens in
China or more particularly in other
parts of the world for so long as it's
not a global watch from